ja bitte gestatten sie aber noch eine
kurze zwischen bemerken weil ich sehr
über das interview nicht sehen konnte
ich bin jetzt hier in kassel ich war
drei stunden auf der autobahn
aber was ich schon seit längeren
längerer zeit seit vielen vielen wochen
bewundere sowohl wladimir klitschko also
auch seinem bruder wittern sind ja wird
bekannte sportler und die haben auch in
ihrer zeit sehr sehr viel geld verdient
wir haben so viel geld verdienen die
könnten jetzt ganz woanders sein
irgendwo unter palmen an einem ganz ganz
sicheren ort und sie bleiben in ihrem
land und das ist sie auch motivation für
die gesamte bevölkerung
da kann ich nur sagen ein riesengroßes
kompliment an beide dass sie sich in die
erste reihe stellen und sagen wir wollen
nicht unser land russland überlassen
deswegen ärgere ich mich auch zum
beispiel ich hätte ihn ansonsten sehr
sein kluger kopf richard david precht
einig der ukraine helfen von etwas leben
wie kommen wir dazu aus der warmen stube
denen die um ihr leben laufen und
kämpfen vorzuschreiben was sie zu denken
und zu tun haben ja blick zurück ich
finde wir sind alle alle dort ziemlich
überrascht gewesen über den angriff
putins auf die ukraine am 24 februar und
ich frage mich ob sich das nicht schon
längere zeit abgezeichnet hat ob wir
nicht zu blauäugig waren und dort rücken
der opposition das war doch bekannt
politische prozesse gegen regimekritiker
mit drakonischen strafen das war doch
bekannt der fall litwinenko der
europäische gerichtshof für
menschenrechte an festgestellt dahinter
steht die russische regierung das
russische regie und 1000 euro
schmerzensgeld sollten an die witwe
gezahlt werden die annexion der krim gut
da haben wir gebummelt und haben gesagt
geht eigentlich nicht das ist
völkerrechtswidrig
einmal im dom bass unterstützung
militärische unterstützung der
separatisten wir haben nicht die
notwendigen konsequenzen gezogen und das
wirtin putin zu den eindruck erweckt
haben auch jetzt beim angriff auf die
ukraine wird der westen nicht so hart
reagieren wie ich das möglicherweise
befürchten deswegen hat er ist riskiert
ja wir brauchen gute verlässliche
stabile beziehung zu russland ja das
stimmt aber wir brauchen nicht nur
sicherheitspartnerschaft mit russland
wir brauchen auch sicherheit vor
russland wo steht eigentlich geschrieben
dass putin halt machen würde wenn er
sich eines tages was wir alle hoffen aus
der ukraine zurückziehen würde ich
fürchte er wird sich dann andere
nachbarn zügeln
die befürchtung von herr bosbach teilen
sie die dass putin nicht mit der ukraine
aufhören wird
er hat ja einige
wegmarken und punkten angesprochen
georgien 2008
krim 2014
auch hier das was wir in berlin erlebt
haben im tiergarten all das sind ja
punkte wo man möglicherweise erwartet
hätte dass man entschlossener
konsequenter handelt dass sich dinge
abgezeichnet haben und zu recht muss man
sich die frage stellen hat man richtig
gehandelt ja oder nein wir dürfen aber
nicht vergessen wir haben es mit einer
atommacht zu tun und das führt eben auch
dazu dass
wahrscheinlich aus diesen gründen heraus
vorsichtiger
bewertungen stattgefunden haben das will
ich an der stelle zu dem appell von
herrn bosbach dringend hinzufügen weil
das kann man nicht einfach beiseite
wischen und dass wir hier als
weltgemeinschaft gegen die aggression
gegen diesen aggressor gegen den
angriffskrieg von putin stehen
dokumentiert 1 dass die weltgemeinschaft
geschlossen dem widerstand leistet und
ganz klar formulierungen trifft und
verabredung jetzt auch trifft die
dringend notwendig sind
also ich muss sagen ich sehe dass
der bus war spricht mir da sehr aus dem
herzen ich glaube natürlich die
bedrohung durch eine atommacht eine
potenzielle bedrohung hat mit sicherheit
das handeln die eine oder andere
richtung beeinflusst dennoch glaube ich
dass wir zum teil naiv an dass wir fähig
waren wir haben einen ex kanzler hier in
deutschland der begibt sich mehr oder
weniger in putins hände der boss von
gerd schröder ist vladimir putin
erarbeitet er bekommt geld für ihn dass
das überhaupt passiert und sich daran im
übrigen auch bis zum heutigen tage gar
nichts geändert hat ist für mich auch
ein zeichen ist für mich sinnbildlich
dafür wie wir mit dieser großmacht
umgegangen sind welches vertrauen wir
geschenkt haben sie blauäugig wir
gegangen sind weiß ich welche aktionen
welche handlungsweisen man hätte anders
machen können dass maße ich mir nicht an
zu beantworten ich fürchte aber ich
würde auf ihrer antwort dann doch noch
eine schippe blauäugigkeit in der ewig
packen aber jetzt stellen sie sich mal
die situation von vor die wir erlebt
haben robert habeck der jetzt gerade auf
energie einkaufstour ist und bilder die
wir aus saudi arabien gesehen haben und
dergleichen wären denn die vor jahren
bewertet worden ich glaube wir müssen
uns das gesamte die gesamte lage
anschauen und nochmal mein appell ist
jetzt nicht zurück zu schauen sondern in
aller deutlichkeit zu erkennen dass das
was jetzt passiert anzuerkennen dass
jetzt die weltgemeinschaft geschlossen
steht dass man sich mit diesen fragen
entschlossen auseinandersetzt dass es
ein
weckruf auch für die nato gibt dass man
sich den zielen verpflichtet auch in
dieses bündnis zu investieren das sind
doch jetzt die dinge die ziemlich laufen
zuschlag erteilen sind die frage an der
stelle in solch heiklen situationen wie
viel zeit darf man sich aber erlauben
weil es ist ja nicht nur einen wettkampf
gegen putin sondern irgendwo ist es ja
dann auch ein wettkampf gegen die zeit
wissen sie ich bin verantwortlich hier
in berlin für die themen im berliner
parlament für das abgeordnetenhaus bin
ich mitglied des deutschen bundestages
ich kann ihnen aber eins sagen aus der
systematik die politik arbeitet dass
politik auch krisen modus kann und vor
allen dingen in der lage ist gerade wenn
herausforderung groß sind auch schnell
entschlossen zu handeln das haben wir zu
beginn der pandemie erlebt das haben wir
jetzt erlebt als die die der
angriffskrieg von putin in der ukraine
begann und deshalb habe ich einen grund
vertrauen in die politik weil ich sie
von innen kennen und weiß auf der brust
kann das bestätigen dass in solchen
fällen entschlossen gehandelt wird das
ist schön ich habe das grundvertrauen
hier nicht mehr als bürgerin also die
korona pandemie als mir genommen jetzt
muss ich auch ehrlich sagen mit blick
auf den ukrainer krieg das so lange die
politik blaues quad oder nochmal
genommen da würde ich gerne eine frage
an herrn bosbach stellen und zwar ist
meine frage war rons heimat hier ein
untersuchungsausschuss gefordert am
dienstag gern ein untersuchungsausschuss
gefordert damit einfach auch mal
überprüft wird wie es eigentlich sein
konnte dass so viele politiker so lange
für putin war oder vielleicht auch mal
die untersuchung wie viel gearbeitet
was halten sie denn von so etwas herr
bosbach
davon hatte ich abstand denn das ist
nicht die aufgabe von parlamentarischen
untersuchungsausschüssen bei
parlamentariern oder
regierungsmitglieder nachzuforschen
warum sie welche haltung eingenommen
haben das ist eher aufgabe von
journalisten
parlamentarische
untersuchungsausschüsse sollen skandal
aufklären eklatantes fehlverhalten
nehmen sie mal anschlag auf dem
breitscheidplatz hätte er sich
verhindern lassen können nsu gibt es
mehrere untersuchungsausschüsse
das macht sinn auch um die frage zu
beantworten wie kann man zukünftiges
verhindern dass so etwas noch einmal
wiederholt müssen wir das recht ändern
brauchen wir mehr personal bessere
ausbildung und so das sind die fragen
mit denen sie untersuchungsausschuss
beschäftigen aber doch nicht mit der
motivation von denen die öffentliche
verantwortung tragen ich würde mal jetzt
als journalist würde ich einmal anfangen
bei einigen nicht bahnen aber einige
kollegen in der ard die sich auch im
deutschen bundestag aufhören als wären
sie die pressen pressesprecher der roten
armee
anfang zur regisseur
wärst du das mit dem
am 8 wer war in die mangel zu nehmen
aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
ein untersuchungsausschuss gibt dann
wird der abgeordnete eingeladen und
haben muss die frage beantworten wie
kommen sie eigentlich dazu so etwas zu
behaupten also das kann ich mir nicht es
gibt da klare formalien der butzbacher
darauf hingewiesen ist ein erfahrener
parlamentarier und ich glaube dem muss
man folgen dem argument auch wenn ich
emotional das verstehe aber was mich so
ein bisschen stört an dieser debatte
dann bin ich selber an czaja ist dieses
zurückblicken glaube es gibt viele die
auch für sich zu recht in anspruch
nehmen können zu sagen werden darauf
hingewiesen
wir haben in kommentaren und sonstwo
sehr früh davor gewarnt auf
einmal wie ich auch nicht immer ein
fester mit allem aber man muss das
anerkennen was er da leistet ist
großartig und setzt sich da jeden tag
wirklich großen gefahren aus und das ist
dass es das ist wirklich eine große
reporter leistung absolut
aber viele sind jetzt so superschlau
nicht und sagen die natürlich alle
geschwiegen haben damals inklusive
lieber bosbach sie aus der cdu weil
natürlich waren es 15 jahre lang auch
unter angela merkel die gesagt haben das
ist ein rein wirtschaftliches projekt
unter anderem aus dem 2 und nichts
dagegen getan haben wobei man auch
angela merkel zu gute halten muss dass
sie sehr klar war in der abgrenzung zum
vladimir putin dass sie da ja wie soll
ich sagen ihre frau gestanden hat wir
haben alle die bilder vor augen also sie
jetzt da wie es friedrich merz gemacht
hat in bausch und bogen zu verdammen
finde ich auch ungerechten übrigen
friedrich merz der sich ja noch vor
kurzem gegen die einführung ging die
ablösung von swift ausgesprochen hat dem
deutschlandfunk vor zwei monaten gesagt
haben wir haben putin die hand
ausgestreckt 2001 im deutschen bundestag
und ich bin sehr erbost darüber dass ist
wie sie ihm damals nicht tatsächlich
auch weiter noch gereicht haben das war
muss man zusehen muss man dazu sagen
bevor überhaupt klar wurde dass wladimir
putin sich viele menschen nicht vorhaben
vorstellen können dass russland eben
diesen angriffskrieg auch wirklich
durchführbar
dazu gehört auch wir jetzt so schlau tut
der muss sich auch messen lassen an dem
was er entweder mitgetragen hat
toleriert hat oder auch propagiert hat
in all den jahren die vor diesen
heutigen abend sind
ich habe nach vorhin großen wert darauf
gelegt ich habe von uns angesprochen ich
habe die regierung überhaupt keinen
vorwurf gemacht auch der jetzt
amtierende nicht wie komme ich dazu ich
kann mich nicht an debatten im deutschen
bundestag erinnern ein gesellschaftliche
debatten an große medien beiträge in
denen wörtlich oder sinngemäß zu hören
oder zu lesen war achtung
die gefahr die jetzt von russland
auszugehen scheint ist nicht nur latent
die kann auch sehr rasch in militärische
gewalt gegenüber nachbarn umschlagen wir
müssen die russlandpolitik ändert ich
habe das nicht mitbekommen was ich sehr
gut noch im kopf habe es noch 72 dass
andere länder europas gesagt haben nein
nicht diese pipeline aber dass die
damalige bundesregierung unter
verantwortung der union an diesem
projekt festgehalten hat mir geht es
doch nicht um vergangenheitsbewältigung
sondern mir geht es um rückschlüsse für
die zukunft
das kennt jeder in der politiker was
jetzt kommt wehret den anfängen
wie können wir verhindern dass
totalitärer autoritäre staaten nicht nur
das eigene volk und die opposition
unterdrücken und bürgerrechte außer
kraft setzen sondern auch aggressiv
werden gegenüber ihren nachbarn in der
zukunft